hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the paul
morphy saga
uh and we are currently uh going to
start the match uh paul charles murphy
versus uh yohanyako blumenthal uh we
already had one match between the two of
them but that was the 1850 match
and this is their 1858 match in london
uh while morphe is still waiting to face
uh
the uh the dungeon master that is uh
howard staunton
now here is uh only one of one very
short
uh clip not clip one very very short uh
well paragraph i would like to read from
david lawson's book regarding this match
but before that
here we have a nice image of this match
there you have it we've already shown
this photo in their 1850 match but we
said that this is actually from the
their 1858 match in london that we are
going to cover
so here it is let's just enjoy that for
a moment you can see
you can see by uh logan paul's uh you
know uh poised that he is uh he
considers
himself morphy superior or maybe he's
just trying to project confidence it's
it's hard to say but you'll see what
happens in the game so this is game two
of their match
uh and the game one ended in a draw it
was a very it was a very nice game
a very equal-ish positional game now
morphe went for the
field or defense and you know that the
game ended in the draw like we said
uh but this is the part i wanted to read
to you guys it's very short so
uh so no worries let me just uh improve
on this
so uh regarding uh this is from uh from
levanthal's uh
uh column uh that he's writing it's uh
it's called uh
the era uh it's being published in
london so under july 18th
uh he says uh we last week informed our
readers that a match uh
at chess was in course of arrangement
between the american champion mr paul
morphy
and herr lovental the arrangements have
been brought to a most satisfactory
conclusion
and the match will be duly commenced on
monday
next july 19th the winner of the first
nine games
is to be the victor uh the stake is 100
pounds aside and
the play is to take place on four days
each week
uh monday tuesday thursday and friday
one game will be played
at each sitting unless adjourned by
mutual consent uh half the game's to be
played at the same george
uh chess club and half at the london
chess club the games are to be
exclusively the property of the players
uh the second
of mr morphy uh the seconds of mr morphy
are lord arthur hey and uh reverend john
owen and
those of mr lowenthal are uh mrs uh
barnes uh
i believe that's like monsignor barnes
or maybe not i don't know not really
familiar with this where it could be
barns uh and uh old ham uh mr stoneton
has been named um the umpire
uh that's the the like the the referee
or the judge and
mr lewis the stakeholder who will be uh
making sure that you know nothing
happens to the money
uh before the end of the match and the
stipulations in this match are
exceedingly simple and fair for both
parties
they are as follows the winner of the
first nine games shall be entitled to
the stakes
the first move shall be decided by lot
in the first game and shall subsequently
belong to each player alternately
wrong games not uh notwithstanding one
half of the game shall be played at st
george like we said in the other half at
the london chess club
uh the play shall take place on the
following days we already covered that
uh each uh either party failing to
appear within half an hour of the
appointed time shall incur
a penalty of one pound one shilling if
you're late for an hour then two pounds
two shillings if you're
late for an hour and a half then five
pounds five shillings uh
uh the fines in each case payable to the
opposite party
no game shall be protracted beyond one
sitting unless adjoined by mutual
consent and
uh point seven after five hours of play
either party shall be at liberty to
demand and adjournment for
an hour and the games shall be the joint
property of the player so this is all
in writing uh and uh here okay we we
could read on but we're not going to
uh basically what it says is that uh the
players did not agree
will there be like a time limit for one
movie is there like can you think for 20
minutes for one move 34 or something
but in for this match you can think for
as long as you want
uh and uh it's uh you know going to be a
problem for morphe
as morphe pretty much plays instantly
and he really hates it when his
opponents uh you know
wait to play moves so this is the like i
said the second game of the match and
love intel really jumped at the
opportunity to challenge morphy again as
he's really
uh well he has to wash down the shame of
losing to 12 year old morphy back in
1850
and now that morphe came here to london
he has no choice but to challenge him
and to you know restore his honor
and his lodging logic is now uh okay
maybe i've lost to morphy at 12 years of
age but i'm definitely not going to lose
at morphe
when now that he's almost 20 years of
age but
as uh you know players say as also
howard staunton said that
his game improved vastly uh since those
days uh talking about low and tall
so let's check out the game we're not
gonna talk this much
uh before every game this is just
because this is now the the start of the
match so let's check it out
morphe with the white pieces opens with
e4 with e5
and now f4 morphe goes for the king's
gambit with bishop to c5
uh going for just a nice developing move
declining the gambit and the knight to
f3 we have d6 now
uh depending on e5 and here we have a c3
not interested in going for the kings
evans right away
uh but rather first c3 preparing ideas
like b4 and d4
we have bishop to g for below until and
now bishop the c4
already uh allowing black to make some
mistakes for example if you just
i think nothing is happening and
continue development let's say knight f6
then f captures an e5 already uh
pressures black into giving up the light
square bishop
because if you go for something like
captures then you run into bishop
captures on f7 and it's already a
problem if you capture then
knight captures with the check picks up
the bishop if you don't let's see
something like this you move the bishop
and now of course white's position is
much better so you have to be careful in
positions like these
so bishop captures on f3 alone gets rid
of the bishop right away
uh we have queen captures and now knight
to f6
uh continuing development and now
preparing the castle
morphe now starts pushing on the queen
side with b4
bishop to b6 and now d3 uh we have
knight beat to d7 or until continues uh
developing and now
f5 morphe is showing very little respect
to low intel
uh overly expanding on the kings side
and of course love intel will make
use of this later on by striking in the
center which is how you want to treat
the position
uh when your opponent overextends on one
side of the board
you should strike in the center so queen
to e7
saying that okay i might castle kings
that i might castle queen side
you you play your game so g4 morphe
preparing g5 so h6
stopping this and now kink the e2 by
morphe morphe playing on both sides of
the board he's saying i'm not going to
castle my king will be very safe on e2
we have c6 bilomental uh preparing d5
now
and g5 by morphe with h captures bishop
captures and
only now d5 striking in the center uh we
have
bishop back to b3 and now queen to d6 d4
is extremely strong here for black
because it really puts pressure on the
b4 pawn
so white isn't really at liberty to
capture on d4 and if you just defend
with a3 then
a5 and the black is breaking through
somewhere so this would be one way to go
the other
way is the way uh that love intel chose
queen to d6 first
uh we have knights to d2 morphe
continues developing and
now a5 preparing to open up the a file
for the rook so morphe captures on a5
we have rook captures on a5 and now h4
morphe starts pushing on the king side
now we have knight
the h5 an excellent move by logan uh
trying to exploit uh
uh the the f4 square somehow for the
moment uh if you if you play it the
white will just capture it but
it could be become uh useful in the
future
so knight to f1 morphy needs to
remaneuver the the knight a little bit
and now
knight the c5 putting pressure on the
bishop here
and here bishop to c2 by morphe so here
you can feel that morphe's position is a
bit shaky and that
there should be something in the
position and in fact there is the
position is completely winning for low
enthalpy uh so feel free to pause the
video here
and win the game for long talk while i
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations as
it's really not the the simplest move to
find
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's actually rook to a3
uh not maybe the first movie that comes
to mind but the point is
you cannot defend the c3 pawn and once
that
gets eliminated then the attack is just
happening and it's unstoppable
point is that it's extremely hard to
defend for example if king to d2 just
decaptures an e4 and
white will not be able to capture with
the pawn uh and here comes uh
the the main thing uh why this knight on
h5 is so great because now
the bishop cannot be used to guard both
the f4 square and
the c3 pawn for example if you try it
with bishop to d2
then you get knight to the f4 check and
now okay okay if you if you eliminated
it then you
the c3 pawn is no longer defended or if
you go king to e1
then you get bishop to a5 piling up on
this
a3 pawn d4 uh the queen and the bishop
now defended but now
everything works for black you can even
play moves like rook captures on c3
which is really really awesome
bishop captures you could play d
captures an e4 now with the tempo on the
queen
bishop captures and now you can play
bishop captures on c3 with
czech queen captures and now knight
captures an e4 and now
okay white is up the exchange but with
the two knights so close to the white
king white king still being in the
center of the board you don't really
have a good move here
uh you have to give up this pawn as well
none of the squares
are here available for the queen to
defend it and of course if queen to b2
than just knight d3 check
uh and morphy loses the queen so rook to
a3 would have been an extremely strong
move here
however uh first uh uh
logantel prepares it with rook to b5 he
wants to go after the bishop this way
instead of
instead of rook a3 to c3 so he wants to
play
rook to beat you now but morphy stops it
he plays bishop to c1
and now we have d captures an e4 now
morphe is again trying to control both
b2 and therefore with the bishop so
knight f4 is always an option for
lowenthal
however he first goes for d captures an
e4 we have d
captures an e4 and now again the theme
of knight f4 just trying to
yeah you know over overthrow the the the
bishop here
but uh here uh love intel goes for
something else and before i show you
this move
even though it's in the thumbnail uh we
are going to give low intel the barnes
head for this move as it really really
needs it
so here lentil plays rook to b2 instead
uh it's it's a very nice idea trying to
trying to really create this beautiful
f4 outpost for the knight
uh but morphy doesn't really have any
other choices he has to capture the rook
so bishop captures
and now knight to f4 check and now
morphy has to be very careful the queen
controls these squares
the bishop controls these two squares so
uh the only square
well uh you don't want to go uh here on
this diagonal and face some nasty
discoveries
so basically king the e1 is your only
option so this is what morphe plays
and now knight c to d3 with check
connecting the fork with the bishop and
b2 so
uh i almost said barnes lowenthal is
regaining some material so bishop
captures the other knight
captures with check we have king d2 uh
again
going in front of some nasty discoveries
but uh if you don't want to
uh well there are a couple of uh options
you could try but none of them really
work you really have to go after the
bishop
so here we have knight captures on b2 we
have king the c2
and the now queen to a3 defending that
knight
knight to c4 was uh was maybe a bit
better but
love intel really wants to finish this
attack but there really
is no way of finishing the attack
because the attack doesn't really exist
uh hence the barnes head so here uh
queen to a3
defending the knight and morphy just
sets a nice little trap here murphy
plays knight to d2
and here uh there really isn't all that
that much you can try because now the
the c4 square is covered you cannot play
c4
what you could play is knight to a4 but
uh
uh of course love intel uh didn't didn't
think of that he played bishop to c7
uh probably to you know preemptively
defend the e5 pawn but here morphy just
wins on the spot
so feel free to pause the video and win
the game on the spot for morphe
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting a move
with the knight back and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
knight to b1 and
after morphy played this knight to be
one move uh until resigned and
well of course there is nothing more to
be done here so here the queen is under
attack if you move the queen you lose
the knight and that's
it there's there's no way to play for
anything here there are no tricks uh
any quintet for check is made by king
captures on b2 and there is no way to
continue the attack
morphe is now up a full rook and of
course
black has black has nothing here yeah
you don't even have a useful check if
you play some like queen b5 check the
king just moves
and there's no way to continue checking
white will just continue developing and
well black really has nothing
so after knight to b1 uh love until
resigned and morphy takes the lead in
this match
uh that will be first in line so like as
uh like
in the previous match we're not going to
show all the games but we are going to
show the the more interesting ones
uh as that's why we're doing the saga
so yeah uh that's uh the game against
johannes bleventhal not on the greatest
path to exact his revenge but
you know the the match still young we'll
see what happens uh i do hope you
enjoyed it
i would like to thank frank combs nick
blackwell west allendale gokul g and
sarah jones larson for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the good
stuff checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day